In history there can only ever be one. The
moniker of the Strongest is something passed
down from titan to titan. Something only a very
talented and blessed individual is capable of
achieving. Hard work and determination means
nothing if the basis of how you build strength
is shaky to begin with. Luckily for Satoru Gojo
his infinite potential is built apon a ground far
stronger than that of a stolen childs stolen
corpse. Having completely annihilated Agito,
who he didnt see as fit to belong in his presence,
its said that with Gojo also having landed a
second black flash his intensity increased and as
he felt a rush of exhilaration flow through him,
he activated his RCT, allowing him to
comfortably heal that previously felled arm.
On the other-hand, and for
the first time in at-least
1000 years, the KING OF CURSES, Ryomen Sukuna
finally begins to feel the weight of battle.
Re-igniting the fight, Gojo stuns
everyone as he lands his 3rd Black Flash,
but this time on Mahoraga. Darting back, he
then takes Sukuna by surprise as he appears
directly infront of him. Sukuna tries to throw a
right hook, but Gojo comfortbaly dodges and grabs
the king of curses hand before adjusting his
polarity and throwing him into mummy Mahoraga.
Not giving them a moment to relax, Gojo
follows up with his fourth black flash.
Luckily for Sukuna Mahoraga was able
to block the strike with the sword
of extermination. Still the impact
from Gojo’s punch, smashed the wall
behind them and sent them sliding back
through one floor of an office building.
Floating outside, Gojo raises his hand and begins
chanting in preparation for his next technique,
Phase, Perfection, Pillars Of Light. In Jujutsu,
A spark is the cursed energy that swells up inside
a sorcerer just before they go to activate
a technique. In the moments before a domain
activation, sure hit technique and other powerful
abilities, there willbe, without exception,
a spark. Even the great Gojo with his immense
cursed energy isn't an exception to the rule.
This fact doesn't change, instead its all the
more obvious for his Hollow Technique: Purple.
Inside of the building and based on
the incantations along with the scale
of cursed energy put in, Sukuna believes
that the spark currently before his eyes,
was that of the cursed technique reversal:
Red. What his plans are in preparation for
the attack is to have Mahoraga tank it then
on top of that adapt to red to put Gojo in
his place. However... Sukuna’s Judgment on
this next attack, was by no means incorrect.
Activating curse technique reversal: Red,
Gojo blasts his ability straight upwards
into the sky, completely confusing
Sukuna. After a second though,
he quickly comes to realize the magnitude of
what's happening and calls Mahoraga forth.
Blasting up through the levels of the
building, Mahoraga shatters each window
as the speed of his movement increases
in an attempt to catch Gojo’s Red.
Moments after Red was fired, Sukuna
figured that by merging the lapse
of blue and the reversal of red,
Hollow technique purple is formed,
producing an imaginary mass that rushes forth.
Shooting itself outside of the building,
its shown that just ahead of Mahoraga, the
Red Gojo had previously fired, was headed
directly at the perpetuated technique
that had crushed Agito earlier, Blue.
In a general sense, the technique; Red in
falls to a standstill before it will explode,
Sukuna was able to figure this out because of
the ability Gojo used on him last time. Mahoraga
was sent up by him to prevent the abilities from
merging. Firstly the shikigami planned to attack
blue and completely erase it as it was already
adapted. All that ran through the beasts mind,
was a yearning to fulfil orders. Travelling at
a rapid speed though and using the attractive
force of his own blue, Satoru Gojo flung
himself between his Blue and Mahoraga.
Blue chooses its targets without bias, and
because it’s attraction isn't affecting the
adapted Mahoraga, as a side effect its caused
his adaption to backfire. Lunging forth,
Gojo lands a fat uppercut that leaves Sukuna with
no one to defend him as he prepares his own last
ditch attack. Pulling his hands up to perform
another use of his piercing blood like ability,
Sukuna plans to disrupt the merging
by causing the explosion of red.
Shooting off his ability, Gojo quickly follows
up and punches the king of curses in his side.
Looking up and seeing his ability about
to clash with Gojo’s, Sukuna confidently
remarks that he was too slow. Unfazed. Gojo
rattles off the incarnation for blue, Phase,
Twilight, the eyes of prajna in such a
short period of time it stuns Sukuna.
Glancing at his attack again, he
watches as it pierces into Gojo’s
steadily merging technique not affecting it in
the slightest. The reason for this is because
Blue was re-activated with restored output
following Gojo’s incantations for the ability.
Floating there with both foes on each
side, Gojo starts his incantations for the
legendary hollow technique, Purple. Nine
Ropes, Polarized Light, Crow and Shomyo,
The Gap Between Within And Without. Witnessing
the battle of the century back at the TV room,
Yuta apologies to Kusakabe San for what he said
previously. As to him its pretty obvious that if
a burden such as himself entered the battle,
then Gojo wouldn't have been able to do this.
With both colors fully combining and the
purple light of the gods themselves growing,
Gojo looks apon both of his terrorfied opponents
faces and finishes the incantation. Purple.
Instantly following the implosion of
the two techniques, an imaginary force
of unstoppable cursed energy exploded outwards,
destroying Mahoraga along with anything in its
path and completely burying all of Shinjuku
under a carpeted layer of rebar and rubble.
Barefoot and barely able to stand, Sukuna
having survived the blast holds himself
up against a broken wall. Infront of him,
Gojo states that well this was an unlimited
purple not bound by any specific target, so
it even damaged him. However as he can see,
its obvious there’s a difference in the
level of their damage. Gojo assumes that
its just because his cursed energy pool is
just that large, so in the and alls well
that ends well! He even jokes that he totally
crushed Sukuna in the improvisation department
with the use of that remote purple, and that its
the first time he’s ever had to blow himself up.
So if you’re confused on how in the world Gojo
was able to just start using cursed energy again,
well its like Kusakabe says and how we
learnt earlier in the series. Gojo was
able to regain his reverse curse
technique because of his use of
black flashes. So now with Sukuna who
has slowed healing, no Mahoraga and an
inability to do any more damage without domain
amplification, it means that for sure 100%
Gojo wins the battle of the strongest sorcerer
in the history of Jujutsu Kaisen’s universe.
HOWEVER does this mean the fight actually
comes to an end? Wellllll nope thats for sure,
we all know that Sukuna has a box with
a bunch of tricks up his sleeve and not
a single sorcerer apart from him, maybe Kenjaku
even knows he has it. Speaking of black box open,
Gojo’s incantation when he says the Gap
between front and back. Like im pretty
sure thats a reference to the cursed dimension.
I might be completely wrong, but when I read it,
it reminded me of Sukuna’s black box open
and Gege’s one shot called No.9. Either way,
if you have enjoyed the video then leave a
like as it really helps out with the algo,
and SUBSCRIBE to keep getting these every week
we have this Gojo vs Sukuna battle. For now
though its been ya professional degenerate
Diavolo and ill see you all in a bit, bye!